in 2018 Facebook's reputation has been
marred by scandals big and small our
social media editor Liz Cho joins me now
to talk about it hey Liz a year to
forget for Facebook it was definitely a
turbulent year for our Facebook Terry
and we can just take a look at some of
the negative headlines that's the
company made in 2018 so I'm sure that
many viewers will remember the Cambridge
analytical scandal so this company to
the private data of 87 million Facebook
users without their permission or their
knowledge and the Mark Zuckerberg had to
testify before the US Congress because
of this and then later Facebook also
came under fire because it had given a
platform to people who spread right-wing
conspiracy theories for example here
Alex Jones of enforce Facebook later
banned Alex Jones are from it's a
platform and just recently we heard a
report that Facebook had given access to
a hundred and fifty companies who were
able to read people's messages private
messages for example Amazon and Spotify
so these companies we're able to read
your private messages and also write
messages in your name and also delete
your private messages so yeah pretty
scary stuff there no not good and the
year isn't even over yet I understand
there's more bad news
yes so on Monday the US Senate
Intelligence Committee released a report
saying that the hackers and Asians the
Russians that had interfered in the 2016
US presidential elections they had
specifically targeted African American
voters in an effort to keep them from
voting for Hillary Clinton so one of the
biggest civil rights organizations in
the US the n-double-a-cp
has called for a boycott of a Facebook
saying that its members should boycott
the platform together with Instagram for
a year the sport called starts on
Tuesday and in fact we're already seeing
this work on getting a lot of support
especially from celebrities
for example here we have the American
comedian Amy Schumer other people who
are joining in our the singer cher who
said she's deleting her Facebook
accounts completely and also the ice
cream company Ben & Jerry's says that it
will also join and avoid a Facebook for
a while to stand in solidarity with the
n-double a-c-p facebook says it has done
what it's called a civil rights audit
and that it is working together with
civil rights organizations to improve
its services so facebook taking a lot of
hits in 2018 but it's not the only
company with this kind of problem how
does facebook compare to other platforms
also Facebook is still the biggest a
social network out there it has about
2.2 billion active monthly users but it
is losing its popularity especially
among the younger generation the
tech-savvy people if you just take a
look at Germany for example statistics
show that if you look at the top
platforms that young people and a twenty
like to use here in Germany you find
that Facebook isn't even among the top
five so Facebook is actually at number
six and also one problem that Facebook
has is that many people are losing the
trust in this company because of these
data scandals so if they continue in
2019 then Facebook could definitely see
itself losing some of its users Leisha
our social media editor thank you so
much